to the Academy Awards Show
good evening ladies and gentlemen I'm
Bob lemon we're at the famous corner of
Hollywood Boulevard in Vine Street near
the Pantages Theatre in Hollywood where
in a few moments the Oscar ceremonies
will begin Oldsmobile is delighted again
this season to bring you the Motion
Picture Academy Awards presentations
it's an Oldsmobile tradition you know to
present the top performance of the year
and later on in the program we'd like to
show you some scenes of a new high-end
automotive performance as we take you on
a tour of exciting California locales
not very far from this exciting spot at
Hollywood and Vine
we'll be going in this beautiful
Oldsmobile super 88 Fiesta along with
our friends here bill and Jane Warren
good evening
we'll show you a famous motion picture
location area we'll visit the new Dennis
the Menace children's playground up in
Monterey and will soar into the air and
a glider over the Mojave Desert I'm sure
you'll enjoy our Fiesta fun tour but now
Oldsmobile on behalf of your authorized
Oldsmobile quality dealer invites you to
be our guests as we go inside the
Pantages Theater and a 29th annual
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences Awards ladies and gentlemen the
overture prelude to a gala evening by
David raksin the Academy Award orchestra
Johnny green conducting
you
you
you
you
the president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences mr. George
Seaton
fellow members of the Academy ladies and
gentlemen good evening and welcome
this year the motion picture industry is
celebrating its 50th birthday its Golden
Jubilee it is a genuine milestone
because for the first time movie
audiences all over the world have more
than a passing interest in these
ceremonies the motion picture has become
as our setting implies a truly global
medium the flow of film between free
countries and the exchange of artists
who created them has increased our
knowledge of an appreciation for our
fellow man one is only to recall the
films nominated in the category of Best
Motion Picture to realize that Hollywood
is roaming the globe not only for
photographic effects but for story
content as well the king and I related
the experiences of an English woman who
went to the court of Siam as a tutor and
stayed to learn the meaning of affection
and understanding the 10 commandments
told the inspiring story of Moses
culminating in the exodus of the
Israelites from Egypt around the world
in 80 days was everything the title
implied except that that colorful and an
entertaining journey was accomplished in
2 hours and 57 minutes friendly
persuasion although of domestic origin
explored a vast region too often
bypassed the human heart
this film gave us the satisfying
privilege of living for a brief time
with warm courageous peaceful human
beings of good conscience and giant with
power and drama brought to our eyes and
ears that strange wonderful exotic land
of milk and honey Texas and now it is my
happy assignment to introduce our master
of ceremonies for this evening's program
as you may recall last year the position
was filled by that gregarious buffoon
that unpredictable irrepressible
uninhibited clown Jerry Lewis this year
our master serum
Oh knees will be that debonair cultured
sophisticated entrepreneur of song and
whimsy mr. Jerry Lewis
thank you very kindly thank you very
much good evening ladies and gentlemen
I'd like to say to 364 days out of every
year
Hollywood strives struggles and works to
prepare for that 365th Day April 15 if
tax day is the big day than Oscar night
is the big night because of the length
of the program tonight ladies and
gentlemen we'd like you to know that if
your name is called for an award please
come and get your Oscar at once
there'll be no deliveries except for
steady customers like Walt Disney of
course now there's a great deal of
tension or nervousness tonight and which
is entirely called for because well this
is a kind of a tense thing here at the
theater and everyone knows that and the
management is asked me to announce that
this performance only the candy
concession in the lobby will not sell
popcorn only buttered Milton
well wait now there's new trading motion
pictures nowadays it's expense now
Warren piece costs nine million dollars
that's more than the real war cost
outside if they don't you do now the
length of these pictures it's fantastic
the other night I went to see Warren
piece and of course I didn't see all the
picture because the kid in front of me
grew up
what have you think that picture is long
I went to see Giants and it cost me $300
$3 admission in 297 dollars for the
babysitter I got home my dog bit me I've
been away so long you thought I was a
stranger there's also another trend in
pictures making this year the picture
making has got a new thing going for
them now Yul Brenner made a picture they
cut off his hair Kirk Douglas made a
picture they cut off the year look when
they get the Mickey Rooney used to be
Gary Cooper
oh yes before I forget I would like to
make mention that last week there was an
accident at the factory where they all
screws a main now one of the workmen
dropped his false teeth into a vat of
molten bronze so will all your winners
please examine your statuettes very
carefully and if your Oscar is smiling
you'll have to turn it back now before
we go before we get into tonight's
presentations the most emotion thing
here you get it the motion big industry
has one very small favor to ask of you
millions of viewers at home all of you
watching all over America and Canada
please ladies and gentlemen please don't
just sit there go to the movies
the first three minutes are always the
toughest and now we take you to New York
to meet a very lovely and gracious lady
who is indeed a credit to our profession
a former Academy Award winner herself
miss Celeste home ladies and gentlemen
oh my jerry i i do find this very
exciting and congratulations on being
selected as master ceremonies for the
second consecutive year
thank you very much celeste it's a big
thrill and you know when i appeared
before the academy award committee and
was told that I was to be master of
ceremonies again this year I was so
surprised I fell off my knees oh no
Jerry you're the ideal choice for me
really really think yeah Oh everyone
agrees that you have such such poise
such charm such dignity you have such
strength you have what the French call
um gonna say quoi
I got that what is it must come up a
suit I never had it before let me let me
let me just give you a little kiss just
to say hello see if we can do this 3,000
miles away just no turn and give me you
need a shave baby you're a little closer
like air good right into the air you
wind it all
what do you say we get on with the award
Celeste I think that'd be lovely I think
all right we'd better be cause tonight
we really have a big big show here
tonight for odes Mabini the big who
tonight on this year stage they'll be
starved really big big stars here on
this few stage here tonight 41 really
big stars and I don't mind telling you
that these are stars they're not golfers
no tennis players no drill teams just
entertainment a television first
Celeste can you hear me honey me just
barely now I can well we're all set here
in New York I have mr. Ward Ogden of
Price Waterhouse standing right here
fine and I'm at mr. Bill Miller of
christ' Waterhouse standing here ready
to head out the top secret envelopes
it's exciting isn't how do you do mr.
Miller to feed money this year it's more
exciting than ever because most of the
presenters are themselves former Oscar
winners or nominees for this year's
awards and the first of these is both a
former Oscar winner and a nominee for
her role in giant Mercedes McCambridge
who has so much to read what would the
technical Awards et cetera et cetera
that she is going to be assisted by
another nominee for his role and written
on the wind
mr. Roberts tank and Miss Mercedes
McCambridge if you please
Bobby how are you Bobby nice to see you
Bob jury these nice to see you you know
Bob Bob Mercedes I'm jelly let us see
you Mercedes Bob take care and I'll see
you the scientific or technical
committee of the Academy did not vote
any class 1 or class 2 awards for 1956
however the Academy is happy to have
awarded class three certificates to the
following to Richard H Ranger of Ranger
tone incorporated for the development of
a synchronous recording and reproducing
system for quarter-inch magnetic tape -
Ted Hirsch Carl Hogg and Edward rashard
of consolidated film industries for an
automatic scene counter for laboratory
projection rules - Thank You papa your
life the technical departments of
Paramount Pictures Corporation for
engineering and development for the
paramount lightweight horizontal
movement VistaVision camera
and sons the dr. C our daily and - the
transparency department of Paramount
Pictures Corporation for the engineering
and development of the high trans and
para high trans rear projection screens
- the construction department of
metro-goldwyn-mayer
for a new hand portable fog machine
I'll bet it's hard to do one of those
and to Daniel J Bloomberg John pond
William Wade and the engineering and
camera departments of Republic Studios
for the nature amma adaptation to the
mitchell camera gentlemen for your fine
contributions the industry salutes you
and now mr. stack the nominations for
the documentary short subjects thank you
Miss McCambridge the nominees are
Charles Guggenheim producer or a city
decides John Healy for the darkwave
Valentine de Diez for the house without
a name Ward Kimball for man in space and
Lois Clyde Stormin for the true story of
the Civil War the envelope please
the winner is the true story of the
Civil War
and now miss McCambridge with a
documentary feature Awards Thank You mr.
stack the nominees are Luis Clyde stolen
for the naked eye Jacques Yves Cousteau
for the silent world and Beyond Henning
Henson for where mountains float the
envelope please
thank you in New York
the winner is the silent world
you